I'd like to discuss a very very
important hormone called growth hormone
in relationship to how to increase it
especially as you age unfortunately as
we age growth hormone just really tanks
if you're over 65 years old your growth
hormone is likely to be 65 percent lower
than what it should be and growth
hormone in an adult versus a child works
completely differently so if you don't
have enough growth hormone as a kid
you're going to be shorter but in an
adult it has everything to do with
protein synthesis I'm talking about
muscle building building of your tendons
your ligaments your collagen your joints
and your bones now what's pretty wild
about this is that the levels of growth
hormone in someone over the age of 60
are equivalent to someone younger with a
growth hormone deficiency pathology or
some dysfunction with the pituitary
gland because the pituitary gland makes
growth hormone so a lot of people are
deficient in growth hormone and they
don't connect the dots on what that's
doing to their body they're going to
have a difficult time building muscle a
growth hormone also has everything to do
with fat burning the breaking down the
lipids or fats primarily in your
midsection
so someone with lower growth hormone is
kind of a problem with muscle building
they're going to have cognitive issues
usually have a lower mood relating to
either depression or anxiety they may
have higher levels of LDL hair loss and
insomnia but growth hormone and
typically an adult uh helps you with
protein very similar to testosterone so
not only does growth hormone go down as
you age testosterone also goes down as
well so growth hormone is produced by
the pituitary gland that's in your brain
and that hormone signal comes down and
works through your liver initially and
it works with this other thing it's like
a hormone it's called insulin-like
growth factor number one now it sounds
kind of a strange name but basically you
can think of that very similar to growth
hormone because it has very similar
functions except for growth hormone has
a more potent effect on fat burning
whereas igf-1 or insulin growth factor
number one has a weaker effect on fat
burning now there's a very important
reason why I brought that up because I'm
going to be talking about the liver in
just a minute but I just wanted to give
you the general function of what growth
hormone does professional athletes that
take human growth hormone uh when
probably they're not supposed to because
it's illegal in many different sports
and it does have a lot of side effects
and but that doesn't seem to discourage
certain athletes from taking it and
there's a lot of people taking other
types of things to try to stimulate
growth hormone I'm I'm going to focus
more on the natural ways that will keep
you out of trouble that don't have side
effects what blocks growth hormone the
biggest thing is insomnia especially if
you have sleep apnea sleep apnea is a
situation where you're you have this
obstruction in your back of your your
sinus cavity or maybe the back of the
throat for some reason and you're not
able to get enough oxygen there's some
interesting connection between getting
enough oxygen when you're sleeping right
in order to sleep so if we have this
imbalance and we're not getting enough
air we're not going to be able to get
enough sleep growth hormone is mostly
elevated during the first part of deep
Delta wave sleep so if you don't get
that you're not going to be able to have
the the benefit of growth hormone in
fact they tested people with sleep apnea
and their growth hormone is much much
lower and even when they wear a CPAP
machine and they get more oxygen okay
that's that mask over their their nose
where they're in their mouth where
they're getting oxygen and their growth
hormone comes back to where it should be
which is interesting so if you can fix
sleep apnea you can greatly increase
growth hormone when you're in a room
when the windows are not open and you're
not getting enough oxygen because maybe
you don't also have enough plants in
your room which give you oxygen you may
have a tendency to have more CO2 in that
room and just that alone can affect your
sleep in a negative way and this is why
when you open the window if you can or
you get a plant next to where you're
sleeping you can definitely sleep better
just for the fact that you're increasing
the oxygen and you're lowering the CO2
so many people
are spending all day in a room with a
higher level of CO2 and not enough
oxygen so this greatly higher CO2
situation can affect
cognitive function especially if you're
like a student and you're taking a test
and you're trying to have the best
intelligent Focus that you can while
having this imbalance of CO2 and oxygen
can greatly affect that but it also
majorly affects your sleep the next
thing that really messes up growth
hormone is something called
hyperglycemia that's too much sugar in
the blood from a high carbohydrate diet
or let's say you're a diabetic that can
inhibit growth hormone and there's a lot
of things that you can do to fix that
like going on a low carb diet but what
you need to know is that one common way
that growth hormone is suppressed is
through either high sugar or high
insulin now this insulin topic is very
interesting because high level of
insulin will suppress growth hormone the
same as a severe deficiency of insulin
so we really need to have normal insulin
and this is maybe a confusion that a lot
of people have with keto they think that
they need to bring insulin down to zero
because insulin is really really bad no
insulin is really necessary it's a
normal hormone we want it normal we
don't want it too high or too low and
unless you're a type 1 diabetic and have
you know loss of the the cells that
produce insulin usually when you are a
diabetic or a pre-diabetic not type 1
but type 2 you can have a situation
where you have high level of insulin and
low level of insulin at this exact same
time now how can that be well because
the body develops this resistance so in
this receptor you have this blockage so
the insulin comes out triggered by carbs
goes into the receptor the receptor is
blocking it so we have low insulin
inside the cell the feedback loop
actually tells the pancreas to produce
more so now we have the situation where
we have more and more and more insulin
and over time the insulin becomes so
weak that it can't regulate the blood
sugars anymore because the pancreas is
exhausted so one really simple way to
know if you have a severe insulin
deficiency is this you want to do a test
a fasting blood glucose test you don't
even have to go to the doctor you can
just get a kit at the local drugstore or
buy it online but it's a blood test kit
and you test while you're fasting maybe
like when you wake up in the morning
normally it should be around you know 75
80. if that blood sugar is higher okay
let's say it goes up to you know 100 115
120 things like that then you know you
have a deficiency of insulin think about
it what's happening when your blood
sugars are going up you don't have
enough insulin to suppress the blood
sugars because that's what insulin does
anytime your blood sugar goes up you
don't have enough insulin and that could
be created from this insulin resistance
situation and one really interesting
thing about a diabetic on a good portion
of their high blood sugar it may not be
a hundred percent from the diet in fact
it's not
a good portion of their high sugar is
because the liver is making too much
glucose it's making it a protein and
even fat and even ketones so that brings
up the next point that I want to talk
about the pituitary gland as one of its
functions is the production of growth
hormone and if you think about these
hormones they're made by glands hormones
are Communications that travel between
different points right from the
pituitary to the liver and then also
there's a feedback loop that comes back
to turn it off so you have this entire
communication going on and my thought is
not to replace
the message or the hormone with some
synthetic version instead why don't we
actually support the gland that actually
makes growth hormone It's A New Concept
for a lot of people but it's much much
wiser because that way you don't mess
with this hormone that can then shut
down the gland so anytime you take any
type of hormone replacement whether it's
estrogen or even testosterone or even
growth hormone you end up causing the
gland that makes it to go to sleep it
atrophies it shrinks it doesn't work
anymore so one really important thing I
think would be good to increase your
growth hormone especially if you notice
a loss of muscle and these other issues
I mentioned is to take a pituitary
glandular support one that I like and
I'm not affiliated with this company I
don't get any Kickbacks or anything but
it's standard process there are
pituitrophin product PMG this is
something I used in practice seems to
work good not by giving you growth
hormone because they take the hormones
out but by giving you the raw materials
to support the gland that makes your own
growth hormone and a lot of people have
reported back that they sleep better and
their nails and hair starts growing back
much better so you might want to make a
mental note of that also stress a little
bit of stress is good for the growth
hormone but chronic stress right it can
really inhibit your growth hormone but
intermittent stress is good as in
exercise intense exercise has the
ability to stimulate growth hormone up
to 2 000 percent and I'm talking about
sprinting as the most intense can help
someone increase growth hormone if you
have a liver problem okay as in a fatty
liver or an inflamed liver or even a
liver that has cirrhosis that can really
mess with your growth hormone so
anything that can improve liver function
will help grow growth hormone and I'm
talking about milk thistle that's
probably one of the best things you can
take to improve many different aspects
of your liver I mean it's kind of like
something that actually counters
poisoning in your liver whether it's you
know from Tylenol poisoning or a snake
bite or poisoning from mushroom milk
thistle counters that but it has a lot
of other cool things it can do as well
and from a diet standpoint moderate
protein can help increase growth from
them that sounds familiar sounds like
the ketogenic diet right now what type
of protein is best the most bioavailable
complete protein the protein that has
basically the best concentrated amino
acids red meat eggs fish all of that is
really really good and also red meat and
other types of meat are loaded with zinc
and if you're zinc deficient you're also
going to be low in growth hormone as
well as testosterone so you want to make
sure you do the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet which includes includes
all these nutrients like all the trace
minerals to help now when you exercise
okay I've talked a lot about doing the
cold immersion or even a cold shower to
help increase anti-aging factors and
things like that but cold therapy also
increases something called heat shock
proteins which increase growth hormone
heat as in a hot shower or a sauna or a
Whirlpool or a Jacuzzi will also
increase growth hormone significantly
even more than cold therapy okay so heat
therapy will increase growth hormone by
a factor of 1500 percent which is even
more than exercise so this is why I'm
bringing this up because maybe you can
combine it and also this heat will help
you sleep at night which will
automatically increase your growth
hormone but I'm not talking about when
you're in the bed staying warm I'm
talking about sometime during the day
getting a sun on them because at night
you want to keep the room a bit cooler
you're going to sleep better and maybe
you just sleep with a sheet or something
like that and the other aspect of growth
hormone is to do intermittent fasting
it's actually very very potent I'm not
talking about necessarily lowering your
calories especially if you're trying to
build muscle I'm recommending to keep
the same amount of calories but just eat
them less frequently so if you did two
meals and you did enough calories and
you didn't snack you have the ability to
increase growth hormone by 2 000 percent
which is pretty fascinating I want to
just bring up the topic of your muscles
okay sometimes people when they get on
the ketogenic diet they feel that the
muscles are just flat they kind of lost
their size they look dehydrated because
when you do keto at least initially you
lose your glycogen stores glycogen is
basically the storage of glucose a lot a
lot of water and potassium and when you
initially cut down your carbs okay
you're gonna also use up some of your
glycogen Reserve and you're gonna lose
water weight okay and uh then your
body's gonna burn more fat you're going
to get leaner but how do we handle this
flat muscle situation well here's how
you would handle it uh there's a real
interesting study with athletes okay
that do keto and apparently there's no
glycogen difference in their muscles
versus someone who's not doing keto they
have the same amount of glycogen now
think about what happens with an athlete
they have to use this glycogen initially
to run a certain way and then if they're
fat adapted they can convert over to
burning fat and they burn three times as
much fat as anyone else they're like a
fat burning machine but what if you're
not an athlete okay and you're not using
up this glycogen to then cause your body
to replenish it you might have lower
amounts of glycogen well number one make
sure you consume enough fluid with the
electrolyte potassium and sodium very
very very important to keep the
hydration of the muscle because we want
to avoid this carb loading bodybuilders
do where they basically just eat a lot
of refined carbs and they just fill up
the muscle with glycogen which is a lot
of it's water so it makes the muscle
look fuller we don't want to do that
because that comes with the package it
creates problems with insulin resistance
but at the same time we don't want to
look dehydrated so we want to make sure
that the electrolytes
including sodium and potassium are
consumed with enough fluid and maybe if
you have a problem with this you need to
bring your carbs up to 50 grams so that
would be roughly about three cups of
berries per day but we don't want to
just do any like straight sugar because
that's going to inhibit our growth
hormone so I've given you a lot of
different things you can do related to
growth hormone and there's a lot more to
learn about this but if you have not
seen this video and how to help someone
with sleep apnea that would be a really
good one to watch I put it up right here